apparently there's some story with
seinfeld he left you on red something
like that
what is that what's your seinfeld story
no that's the other thing to krista
stefanos
which is terrifying you know texting i
have his phone number and you know i
grew up with the guy watching him on tv
so text it's like texting a supermodel
where i write it then i delete
everything and then i edit and i'm like
is this funny enough what i'm asking
people
so it's so scary to text him so when he
leaves you on red woo it stings yeah but
uh he left me on stage once or no i
opened for him and i got off too early
because i didn't want to go along and he
wasn't there yet yeah and he he's very
meticulous about how he runs his show it
was completely my fault and so then i
ran back out because i couldn't leave an
empty stage right and then i started
bombing i got heckled you're like
where's jerry bring out jerry and i
wanted to trash this guy but you got to
be clean so i didn't want to [ __ ] up the
show
so the whole thing sucked and he was
upset about it yeah and then i got i got
a kind of like
scolded by a childhood hero as a very
surreal moment yeah and then what
happened after that well we were totally
cool but i actually think it brought us
closer because he could he felt like he
could be honest with me that's awesome
but yeah it was at the time early did
you do like i was supposed to do 15 i
probably did 12
or 13. and he wasn't there yet he was
kind of honest he was in an elevator on
the way down wait going to the stage and
it was a split set i got off and the
stage example like what do i do and
there was some grip on his phone playing
a casino game he's like you better go
back out there and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i went back out there and that was
the worst move i could have done you got
heckled pretty bad on that one because
they were like you again we don't know
[Music]